Austan asks Gary in episode 63 you say
you watch and can tell if people are
hustling how do you tell engagement
frequency or gut also this is a great
question I love the recall to that long
long long time ago episode number 63
yeah I mean this is how I do it and
funny I'm I'm in love with this answer
and like you know 20 I by the way I'm
giving you a a pre alert that I think
the answers on this show are gonna be
really good I feel up for today's answer
I'm gonna go even deeper I remember why
I started this show which is can I go
deeper on all my quotes for my fans I'm
gonna challenge myself in this episode
to go deeper both in the tactical
aspects and the theoretical aspects and
what I mean by that cloud and dirt by
the way what I mean by that is how do I
figure that out is very simple it starts
with the fact that I put in work so when
I go look at your Twitter account and
your Instagram account I will actually
click your posts I will actually look at
all your posts I go to everybody's if
you go to a Twitter account you can hit
their profile and then you can save you
all with replies right so if you go my
account twitter.com slash Gary Vee
you'll see all my non reply tweets
anybody go Gary's pushing out a lot of
stuff but if you click with replies all
of a sudden you get a much deeper
picture into what I'm actually doing on
Twitter which is I'm engaging at scale
with my community so when I get pissed
at all of you one of the things I'm
looking at it I'm like oh look at all
these 15 people that I just got the last
35 minutes looking at when I click their
Twitter account because they just engage
with me I'm double checking so I just
click very quickly usually on my phone
okay cool you say hello I mean let's do
one right now real time baby let's do
one right now very simple this is gonna
be interesting
somebody's about to get really called
out right so you open a Twitter app
right and I go to my notifications and I
don't know what I'm gonna get here do
you rock do your best but I look and
I'll be like you know social media
Twitter right well you know social media
twtr this dude right he says he's been I
asked how long have you been following
me a lot of you answered thank you by
the way right so I'll click in and I
look at him and I'll say okay a thousand
ten eighty and then I'll look at what
he's actually doing and I see does a lot
of retweeting okay that's interesting to
me right he's doing a ton of retweeting
cuz that's for his account so that gives
me a sense of what he's doing I'm gonna
skip ahead cuz he's kind of playing
that game now Kristin will say great
point by Gary V thanks Kristin and I'll
go into here LCC has 7,000 followers
they'll give me some information and
then I start looking at what she's doing
and then she's engaging she's engaging
she's engaging he or she's retweeting
she's hitting that person up I love this
hey saying to somebody they love the new
profile [ __ ] this is starting to give
me a sense and actually Christine let's
give her some let's give her some DAPs
can you zoom in top right corner are you
able to do something there to give her
some DAP so she gets some pink Club you
know so she's doing a good solid amount
of engaging she's doing some nice solid
retweeting she's actually really
engaging oh crap like I don't know I
didn't want to curse there if you look
now go over here dear akka this is very
faint but you can see they're gonna
bring it up shore on the all the way in
the right where it's just one hour one
hour two hours can you see that on the
right here it's very small but what I'm
seeing is that she's I mean this is all
happening in the last two hours a lot
happy engagement she's crushing the
engagement there so then the next thing
I'll do when this is work like like if
anybody understands like like how do i
how do I know cuz I'm putting in the
work next thing I do is I hit her URL on
her Twitter account which is radical dot
social right and then this pops up and
now I'm looking at this is her blog as
this is where she works I don't know yet
but here we're about to look okay now
I'm looking and I'm like do you know
there are tons and I'm like what is this
I'm trying to figure it out and
sometimes if I don't figure it out
quickly I'm like I don't know what this
is I'm out looks like your blog like
talk to me like you know like this is
hitting up Chris anyway so these are the
things I'm doing I'm analyzing right I'm
looking at the other thing to do if I
was looking at my Instagram I look at
the pictures what does that person put
out and what I'm seeing my friends and
the reason I called out so many people
is one I'm seeing the far majority
people only in the right hook business
right thanks to Christine here I'm in a
good mood because he's jabbing the [ __ ]
out of it right so that's great but then
there's other things is she throwing
right hooks is she trying to drive
people like cuz the right hook is part
of the jab jab jab right hook which is
the overall thesis put out great content
create value upfront convert it into
business and so when I see people and I
see a lot of you asking the same
questions about your coffee business
your catering business all this I'm
trying to see if you're doing that mix
are you only right hooking are you only
jabbing are you driving people
successfully is your is your website
responsive because it's a mobile world
these are like I do this like as you
could see that alone I'm not even done
with Christine like auditing that alone
is five seven nine minutes that's
insanity in a world where I'm so busy
but that is the reason so many of you
follow me I truly believe that I believe
in this karma Zen kind of aspect to it
that I'm capable of giving great answers
on this show cuz I know you way better
than you think in a world where every
one of my contemporaries that's at my
level whatever that is thinks that the
last three minutes of this show the
things that I do with my time in a world
where in my inbox I mean let's let's
like to break this down let's understand
what I'm talking about in a world where
I've got all these emails right now and
like going back and so I hope some of my
clients are gonna get upset here I think
but like here's a very important email
from John the lead developer at Wine
Library about a new program that we're
about to launch online better come from
Friday not answered yet right because
I'm looking at Christine's Twitter
account nobody no businessperson thinks
that's the right move none and so I
think if you want to pop if you want to
be an anomaly you've got to act like one
[Music]